[Music]
would you let your six-year-old start a
fire or use a hammer and saw for decades
special playgrounds in the UK have given
children free rein now the concept of
adventure play is slowly spreading in
the United States
brook silva-braga visited playgrounds on
both sides of the Atlantic to learn more
and is here with what he saw Brooke
good morning well if you grew up on
slides and swings these adventure
playgrounds can be pretty shocking they
often look more like junkyards there's
usually no normal playground equipment
not many rules no direction on what to
do
organizers say they'd like to see a
bunch more of these open across the US
but that will take some new thinking
about what playgrounds and childhood are
supposed to look like while some kids
hammered and others sawed Jonah Schwartz
got an idea that's true and so the 11
year old started building an addition to
the playground suggestions do you think
this thing's gonna hold this is
playground NYC 50,000 square feet of
dirt where the boundaries of childhood
have been redrawn this is a space where
children can make their own decisions
about what is quote unquote risky
Rebecca Faulkner opened the adventure
playground last summer joining a tiny
handful of spaces in the US that give
kids dangerous tools and invite them to
make a mess you're actually making mud
we are wood making mugs what is very
popular the staff called play workers
offer some supervision but very little
direction adventure playgrounds first
blossomed in the UK after World War two
one of them was Glamis still open here
in East London hey what you want is a
free place you just have
you can't do anything that they'll say
no you can't do it you're just free how
free well after taking a sledgehammer to
these wood pallets we watch the kids
pile up the broken boards and set them
on fire if it all looks a bit dangerous
the workers here like penny Wilson say
that's the point
you think the risk is a positive I think
the risk is definitely a positive
children are doing things that children
are perfectly capable of but we as
adults decide that they're not because
we feel uncomfortable but even in London
that argument has faced pushback and
adventure playgrounds have been changing
or even closing in part over safety
concerns in the u.s. 61 pages of federal
playground guidelines now warned against
everything from grass to rope swings
that's why playground NYC isn't actually
in New York City but on Governors Island
a former military base just south of
Manhattan Governors Island is unique
there are different rules here that
don't apply to the city this is like an
outlaw playground take a ferry you have
to take a ferry you have to find it it's
a destination but even here we saw signs
America may not quite be ready for a
London style adventure playground
parents here are required to sign a
legal release not so in the UK and
unlike London adults are not allowed
inside why we asked Ed play worker Luke
Sutton who used to run an adventure
playground in Wales do you notice a
difference in the kids in Wales in here
no plays yeah do you notice the
difference between the parents yeah
parents here leaned against the fence
and tell the kids what to do it and how
as though they're not innately capable
of that already
but Rebecca says the parents aren't kept
out just for the children's sake but as
part of an effort to retrain the parents
to leave their kids alone you cringe a
little bit you know you wanna know that
your kids are safe also she stepped on a
nail okay embracing the freedom of
adventure play may be easy in theory
guys but what happens when someone steps
on a nail
when it happened to Addison block we
noticed her mom Jill let her other
daughter
keep playing we went in knowing that
it's a place they could get hurt it's
the type of experience that kids in the
city you don't want me to get I think
that's great
would you bring him back absolutely yeah
play work is on a human level it's a
direct challenge to the dominant
paradigm of childhood that being that
children a week that children are
incapable that children needs to be
protected and held and sheltered from
the fears and dangers of the world but
if that were true then we as a species
would have gone extinct long ago Luke
the head play worker said he blamed
himself for Addison stepping on that
nail he says there's a difference
between risks and hazards and it's his
job to eliminate hazards like a nail
hidden in the dirt but risks like
swinging a hammer or standing high above
the ground those are things the kids
need to conquer themselves and we should
point out you could even step on a nail
and then regular playground I've done it
I've done it you can and they say
actually accidents are no more common at
these playgrounds than an ordinary
playground but that supervision part I
mean they're at least they're those
playground workers right there are play
workers there all the time it's actually
one of the reasons these playgrounds are
expensive to maintain you need staff all
the time and it's led to some closures
because that's hard to afford this these
do look like the junkyards that every
kid wanted to play in they are in a lot
of especially older people we spoke to
said this reminds me of the kind of free
childhood I had that's become
increasingly uncommon doesn't say that
the junkyard that they were playing in
parents didn't know yeah brook
silva-braga thank you